welcome back well as you saw before the
break Mike Comrie has to decide in the
Brecon and radish of by-election and
joining us now is the party's leader
Adam price thank you for being with us
it's a bit strange for a Welsh
nationalist party to not stand a seat in
Wales it's never an easy decision I
think for uploading a party to test it
to stand down
but you know we live in unique times and
I think this moment called for a new
approach I mean particularly we're about
to well you know few days to to be de
Porres de new Prime Minister with a
terrible you know frightening policy on
on brexit and I think at this time you
know we're gonna be we're gonna be
dealing with the consequences of what
may happen in the weeks and months ahead
for a generation and I think that's why
we had to do what I think many people
have been hoping for but you know
Bracken and Radner is a template for
potentially something much bigger which
is people coming together across party
recognizing of course where different
political parties with with differences
amongst us but on at this time on this
issue we need to build that why do you
think this is effectively a blueprint
that could be extended to other seats I
I very much hope so so I immediately
after the European elections I I'd wrote
to all the leaders of the proa main
parties those talks were already
happening when of course then the the
petition happened for the for the
by-election and the by-election now is
the platform I think we're we're I hope
you'll be able to demonstrate that this
can work and you're having those
conversations and with other parties yes
yes they're ongoing and you know I mean
we've we're not doing this III believe
for a one-off we're seeking to build the
basis for that wider remain alliance and
as you solve the analysis from James a
few minutes ago
you know this could be very very
significant I mean this could be a
game-changer in terms of the electoral
map if there is a snap election called
then this could make that all the
difference in terms of what's going to
happen in the in the months ahead at the
same time in some ways Bracken and
Radner sure was an easy call to make
I mean you guys have historically done
pretty poorly there haven't you haven't
been big contenders I mean is this not
more about you know making sure you
don't lose your deposit rather than
anything else well III think it yeah
it's certainly I think hope for
fertile territory for you no letter for
a remain alliance but I think you know
in a sense we're breaking the mold here
I mean politics by its nature its
culture is very tribal you know
political parties find it very difficult
to work across those divides difficulty
won't in whether or not to run in a
constituency where you actually have a
shot of winning well look I mean
obviously in in terms of any discussions
then actually sitting down and then
working out if we get if we get to that
stage who stands down where that's
that's where the nitty-gritty but I
think if you're able to establish the
principle on a positive basis
demonstrate look with goodwill it's
possible for political parties to come
together on this particular issue which
is a defining question of our generation
and you know I think that we've had such
a positive response it's almost as if I
think the public sometimes they're ahead
of you know the the cultural political
parties the public wanted this you know
at this at this testing time in politics
I think people want to see us working
together across those party boundaries
because what you know what unites us on
this issue is far more important at this
time than anything that divides us if
you're talking about what the public
wants what the public wanted in Wales at
the time the referendum was to leave the
EU so why are you the self-styled party
of Wales campaigning for another vote
well look I mean I'm in the persuasion
business right I mean at the moment
about 20% of the population in Wales
support independence it's rising by the
way probably because of the shambles
that his Westminster brexit at the
moment right but we want to actually
build that and in the same with the
European issue right we want want to
persuade the people of Wales that
actually the brexit that is on offer is
not in our national interest can you
imagine having a referendum on Welsh
independence after campaigning for so
many years people voted out and then
actually the politicians like oh no
let's give you another go I actually
said I think two days after the the
referendum in 2016 that they would
always have to be you know as a second
public vote the second referenda because
it was different to the independence
referendum in Scotland where there was
you know there was a thick dossier a
white paper presented to every citizen
in Scotland explaining in fine granular
detail what that meant
well no voters weren't told the
politicians failed and in fact many of
them lied as we know no and that's the
problem and that's what's left us you
know in the three years since we've just
been going around in circles constantly
that's why we need a second referendum
in order to finally determine the future
okay thank you very much for coming on
the program this morning thank you